would you consider yourself a feminist  yes okay do you think do you want  equality yes so when it comes to  equality do you think that  women should make up like 50 of the  military  no why if you want equality I don't like  I'm I think I'm anti-military so I don't  really believe in like people going to  war like fighting and stuff okay I also  don't believe that like women should  have but it should force me like should  be forced to fly I do feel like that men  are physically able to do things that  like women would have to train a lot  longer to do so I don't think it's fair  to make a woman do those kind of roles  and yeah like I feel like not all  Elements of Life have to be 50 50 for  equality to be there